la haine portée par les islamistes est à
son paroxisme en France et les forces de
l'ordre sont sur les dents entre menace
de mort contre un journaliste injure
publique envers des responsables juif et
interpellation lors de la manifestation
interdite en soutien à la Palestine
mardi matin au cri de Allah Akbar vous
allez tous y passer une femme
intégralement voilé a menacé de
perpétrer un attentat sur la ligne du
rerc à Paris avant d'être neutralisé par
des tirs de policiers dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi dernier l'imam de la
mosquée de ber a été interpellé pour
apologie du terrorisme ce religieux
radical de 32 ans déjà connu des
services de renseignement a été cueilli
à l'aéroport de Marseille alors qu'il
revenait d'un pèlerinage en Arabie
Saoudite le 12 octobre dernier à
Montpellier c'est un élève de 13 ans
dont le père est parti en Syrie qui a
été exclu temporairement de son collège
après avoir dessiné des croix gamé et
répété plusieurs fois sa haine des Juifs
en lien direct avec le conflit israélien
l'apologie du terrorisme elle est
passible de 5 ans d'emprisonnement et de
75000 € d'amende 7 ans et 100000 €
d'amende si les menaces ont été commises
via Internet la haine en ligne justement
n'a jamais connu un tel retentissement
pas moins de 6072 signalements ont été
répertoriés de depuis les attaques
terroristes du Hamas en Israël le 7
octobre c'est sans oublier les quelques
5263 islamistes qui vivent en France
tous inscrits au fichier des signalement
pour la prévention de la radicalisation
à caractère terroriste tout cela
contribue au djihadisme d'atmosphère
comme le décrit Gill kepppel qui place
le pays sous très haute
tension